[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
everybody knows it
John Whitaker touches you he hurts you
come for you John chicken don't hide
fabric
right through the city
right through the city like British if
you ain't thick please don't give up
now Brandon
what's up fam Monday morning October
17th it is a glorious morning shout to
Jesus Christ what is happening
um yep I'm dressed like Mr Rogers today
like a high Beast Mr Rogers won't you be
my neighbor
did Mr Rogers drink on the show he sure
did it was just off air he was hammered
90 of the time he's he enjoyed his life
chatting about snotty knows kids and
have him sit on his lap and [ __ ] and
that beat down basement you know he was
a sniper in the military like one of the
most decorated snipers what
dude was a Savage yeah dude you do not
either huh Mark murder yeah Beast
Roger is the host of international
acclaimed TV show for children Mr Rogers
Neighborhood serves as a Navy SEAL
Marine scout sniper during the Vietnam
Ward ever heard of it with a large
number of confirmed kills
you have to stay as false Mr Rogers
never certainly maybe that's like an
urban legend then nah dude that's real
oh you haven't seen the
um
uh Tom uh Tom Hanks plays Mr Rogers you
haven't seen it that's right there he is
yeah he just blown people's heads off
Vietnam
that's the it's the extended version
you'll find on the dark web
it's called the dark the dark Rogers
dark Rogers yeah uh see the we get
started with shot this one miss Rogers
was not an abcr Scout marine sniper this
is a great urban legend 21st century
um the rumors well we're rooms that Mr
Rogers the host of the international
acclaimed TV show Mr Rogers Neighborhood
served as the Navy SEAL Marine scout
sniper during Vietnam era with a large
number of confirmed kills we have to
State it's false Miss Rogers never seen
the military after another rumor uh Miss
Roger always wore long sleeve clothes to
concealed tattoos of all his kills yeah
dude he had like a skull he had like you
know the hardcore dude this
things full of [ __ ] this is Navy
sales.com the fact this is Navy
seals.com oh well yeah well maybe
someone hacked their page uh firstly
Miss Rogers was born in 1928 this is the
time the UC involvement Vietnam conflict
was too old to enlist in the US Navy
um yeah but V oh yeah because if he was
born in 28 Vietnam was what 72 and then
what 75 yeah he's gonna be too old
conclusion from the above the obvious
reasons mentioned above dumbass Miss
rajkin have never served in the military
he was personally choosing to wear long
sleeve clothes because he had uh KKK
tattoos wow interesting no it doesn't
say that
um keep his clothes I always joined to
keep his clothes just to be formal yeah
surprisingly nobody called him Fred and
he wanted to keep it that way
interesting his name was Frederick
Rogers Fred Rogers
wow the more you know dude we didn't
have internet when I was a kid
you know we just didn't have Internet
it's like the same urban legend uh some
of this room did acid this weekend and
the first thing I said was oh my God
were you where are you gonna peel your
skin off like an orange
and
comes out that was the urban uh Legend
created by the Dare program shout out to
Crime uh McGrath the crime dog I think
he started that
um where if you there's this urban
legend of a guy taking acid and he
thought that he was a big juicy orange
and peeled his skin off and died
as you get older you think about just
the logistics of that and you're like
seems
not realistic but I've never done acid
so I'm going to stay away from it so
that's also urban legend
but none of that matters none of that
matters because UFC 280 is here kids and
uh your boy's been so busy you know I
look at the cards
you know maybe the week before whatever
you know I do my homework for the show
and stuff like that and you've had some
you know fight nights or which whatever
and I didn't realize that UFC 280 is the
best card of the Year quietly I mean
that that December 10th card if John you
know fights deep a there and and they
added Yuri is Up For Debate and there's
been some good cards this year but
on paper on paper from prelims the main
card the UFC gave us a little treat
Christmas came early kids Christmas
forget your Halloween candy this is your
this is your Halloween candy and it's
better than candy corn kids UFC 280 is
the heck because I was gonna say stacked
switched it it's thick dude this card is
thick it's tasty it's so tasty for the
first time ever if the boys can pull it
off this is what it's like to work for
me I
um started doing my homework on UFC 280
yesterday I'm looking into everything
I'm like oh my God I am why am I rock
hard do I do my homework on this car
your boy is rocked up the entire time
because the the card is
silly dude the card is stupid as the
kids say so I'm looking over it and I'm
like man I wish we could do a cow bass
fight campaign for this oh I'm on the
road in Salt Lake City and usually
that's a bummer because again none of
the bummer life is great but best job in
the world but also when you're on the
road my shows actually line up when the
UFC main event starts or main card
starts so if I'm gonna run I get a bunch
of Tours uh tour dates coming up someone
missed a few fights but
um usually I'm on the road when some of
these big pay-per-views happen and you
know it's a nightmare to pull off a
fight campaign if I'm not here it's
impossible to do
so I got the old
brain working and I thought wait a
second what time is this main card start
the paper you start 11 A.M Pacific time
which is 12 so Salt Lake City time well
that's way before I have to go on stage
I bet we could do for the first time
ever
a Salt Lake City fight companion I just
need to get a guest on there because my
the guys I bring on the road to comics
you know they don't know anything about
fighting nor the instrument so that's
not going to work and I thought who else
could I get and then I remember a
gentleman by the name of Franklin mayor
Franklin and his buddy Harrison uh who
can make a big announcement about the
fight they've come up but Franklin mayor
Junior and Harrison said
um hey we want to see do stand up so
we're gonna fly from uh Frank's gonna
fly from Vegas to come to your show on
Saturday and then I remembered oh yeah
what if Franklin got there a little
early
I fly the boys out I'll find a studio
out there because the buttery Bros are
out there and what we set up an old Salt
Lake City fight companion for UFC 280.
that would be fun
so the team has to figure that out and
it's Monday and I told them at 8 A.M
this morning but Franklin's in Almond
all you guys do is get the cameras all
you do is get the streaming good Wi-Fi
Studio but buttery Bros gonna help me
out shut the battery Bros they're in
Salt Lake City so get your mind right
kids at uh on Saturday at noon
Mountain Time
which would be 11 A.M Pacific time there
will be a live Salt Lake City fight
companion with Frank Mayer and myself
maybe some other guests but all you
gotta know is it's my thick ass and
frankman my skinny my enemies so it's
too thick boys you got Frank Mayer and
myself doing a UFC 280 Salt Lake City
fight companion maybe for my health
maybe from my hotel room maybe from a
dope ass dude out there the Buddy Bros
are setting up I don't know Chin's gonna
be there Casey's going to be there
setting it up Mark Harley's gonna be
there the whole squad's gonna be there
we're all it's it's road trip road trip
it's road trip time Salt Lake City's not
far it's UFC 280. if this card wasn't so
goddamn stacked I would never bend over
backwards like this now I say bend over
I mean text you guys to get it done you
know what I'm saying but then I got a
big deal still though it's a lot of work
for everybody Ruben's making the graphic
right now get your mind right thick boy
YouTube Only Live we're going live at 11
7 A.M Pacific time for UFC 280 baby and
let's just get right into it shout out
to San Jose uh there this past weekend
Josh Thompson came out had a great uh
lunch meeting my boy Rich ciao this is a
grand old time there and I love San Jose
it's actually one of my favorite cities
the new Green Room Diaries I'll be
dropping we should maybe get out today
or tomorrow
um I'm gonna get another one on Thursday
I go
pretty hard your boy Garcetti knew
something just a heads up
um
shout out to San Jose man one of my
favorite freaking clubs but then
literally my favorite Club first Club to
ever give me like a full on the road
headlining weekend I'm there this
Thursday Friday Saturday
Wise Guys Salt Lake City shout out to
Keith so my favorite venues of all
freaking time Salt Lake City's always
been great to me
um come on out Salt Lake I can't wait
man I'm so crunk and I'm I'm so excited
to do these uh the fight companion on
the road
I I'm not sure how many big
pay-per-views can be like this at a noon
start time but if they are that makes it
better for me but the fights have to be
in like Dubai or some [ __ ] to pull that
off but let's just get into uh the UFC
280 man and where do you start first of
all for Muhammad and Sean Brady not to
be on the main card hurts my feelings
has to hurt both their feelings being
the main event on the prelims your boy's
been there
I've been there that means
um you know those tend to get more views
than the pay-per-view because people
have to pay for it and uh they're trying
to introduce new blood into the uh into
the general audience and Muhammad who's
been around for a hot second he's been
on food truck great guest on food truck
he's a Savage from Chicago uh he's
fighting
the Philadelphia badass in Sean Brady
and Sean Brady if uh the hardcores are
super familiar with them but if you're
just a casual tune into this draw as
you're driving to work and you're like
ah I'm not sure if I I'm gonna tune in
I'm telling you you're going to want to
tune in Sean Brady at welterweight and
welterweight is pretty pretty tasty Sean
Brady I'm telling you guys is the guy is
the next guy his back looks like he has
a big barrel of just liver all over just
liver Jeffrey Dahmer Style Just liver
liver on it just just all sorts of
grooves it's like the Grand Canyon back
there he's tatted he has a cheat on the
back of his neck
that's what you're dealing with dude and
he's Philadelphia's finest and there's
something going on in Philadelphia and
just ain't the cheesesteaks because the
Philadelphia Eagles are undefeated which
nobody saw coming even though they
signed AJ Brown all that stuff still
nobody's thought Jalen Hurst can be the
leading candidate for nvp so there's
something going on not only in their
cheesesteaks but also in their water
because chambray is undefeated at
welterweight he's getting his first big
big test with uh Muhammad and I'm
telling him get on the Sean Brady
training now I love Muhammad absolutely
love Muhammad one of my favorite guests
such a good dude has a future in
commentating analyst work his podcast is
super unique and uh he's crushing it
such an amazing fighter too
amazing fighter
John Brady's a tough matchup for him I'm
all up on Sean Brady's tatted nuts I
don't know if they're tatted but your
boy is all up on his dad and nuts he is
a [ __ ] Savage kid and you might as
well get on the get on the Sean Brady
train now already the Eagles are hot so
you might as well get on you know the
Sean Brady train because Eagles are
popping Sean Brady's popping he's a
handsome bastard too he couldn't look
any more like a Philadelphian
and his hats are super clean oh they're
good yeah
it's such a good fight man
yeah this dude's Jiu Jitsu is [ __ ]
Next Level his grappling so it you know
here's the thing about uh Muhammad too
khabib's in his corner like he's and he
came on a food truck I think Sam food
truck was not fair I forget we've done
so many but he came on food truck he was
telling me that he's trained with khabib
and how intense it is and how it scares
the train with khabib because when you
train with khabib and you're with his
team it's so serious he was like I was
like Jesus Christ but uh khabib is corn
um Muhammad and Abu Dhabi something be
said about that so I'm sure he's been
working with him because Brady's bread
and butter is going to be choking people
out so we're gonna see if Muhammad can
avoid the takedown uh Muhammad's you
know just a guy he's a bit of a sleeper
he just he you look at his strength
scheduling like his resume he's a
monster dude there's reason he's ranked
So High
um but Sean Brady is my Dark Horse to be
a champion in the next
I'll say two years because wow probably
under that because he beats Muhammad
Muhammad's ranked watching
because it's chambray's listen he's not
a feed he's been deserving a big fight
for a while and you know it's not the
hangout
Muhammad's five
Sean Brady's eight champagne beat Wonder
Boy he beat Neil Muhammad yep yep yep
yep so it's off the races so I say two
years you're out of your mind run next
year
man it's uh dude he beats Muhammad
they'll probably jump him to five
you look at Gilbert Burns hamzat Colby
Camaro Leon Edwards
um Sean Brady matches up very well
against Hamza a good fight against Kobe
Kobe's gas tank we haven't seen chamber
you get pushed like that for five rounds
Colonel usman's and it's John could beat
Leon Edwards kids give me a prom he's
he's gonna be in that top five for quite
some time to get familiar with him
that's just the prelims kids that's just
the prelims Philadelphia and Chicago's
Finest Muhammad Sean Brady and then for
the main card which again I'm doing Salt
Lake
City fight campaign with Frank Mayer at
11 A.M Pacific Time on thick Boy YouTube
but just the main that was the the
prelim
Main Event so for the main card you got
I mean any one of these
two of these fights could fall on the
card's still [ __ ] stacked so you got
uh Darius versus gamra which is a
ridiculous fight Darius is one of those
guys that lightweight where he kind of
falls under the same umbrella as Leon
Edwards uh as like a John Fitch as those
guys who probably deserved a title shot
about a fight or two ago but just
doesn't check the boxes in regards to
the UFC's marketing plans so by the time
a guy like Darius or by the time a guy
like Leon Edwards did a title shot it's
well overdue and uh they have to walk
through absolute [ __ ] fire in order
to get a title shot for whatever reason
the the UFC
it's not that they're denying my title
shot but if you know if you look at the
way they've treated like um
you know you look at the way they've
treated Peter uh pierra who's fighting
uh Izzy you look at his strength of
schedule or experience the inordia title
shot you look at like a um even a uh
Sean O'Malley like hey he's had some
fights but you look at his level of
difficulty to get to Peter Young he's
the number one you know guy in the world
they they have their marketing and they
want certain guys get their title shots
you know Darius falls under that one to
kind of Leon Edwards the Tony Ferguson
you know for whatever reason they just
don't check a certain box so ufcs can be
like dude good luck like you know what
John Fitch had to go through and he
already got a title shot now a lot of
these guys when they do they do get a
title shot you better take advantage of
it it's only happening once like you
look at the fire a lot of these guys
have to walk through to in order to get
a Top Shot who aren't marketable UFC's
going all right you can get your chance
hopefully you get above if you come
champ but if you were to lose
see ya you're never getting a towel shot
again dudes kind of checks that box he's
uh his thing is though he's exciting
they'll finish people he'll bite down
his mouthpiece which can be a detriment
to his career but you know he'll sit
there and trade shots he's won a few
performance tonights a few fight of the
nights Savage on the feet Savage on the
[ __ ] ground I know him strictly from
Jujitsu years and years and years ago uh
but he's really you know taken off and
he's doing the damn thing
um you know gamron is um
they're not doing Darius any favors here
gamerat's not a guy who you're gonna
look good against gamrat's a guy where
you might win but you're gonna know
you're in a fight game right is a
[ __ ] Savage you know and there's uh
there's a common theme I'll get to it
when we get to the the main event but
there's a theme here you have the new
the new class coming up man you have the
new class coming up and gamraat's one of
those guys he's the new class he's gonna
be around for a long time
um the the the it's like it's like Game
of Thrones you know the older Kings
dying older King being uh you know
Charles Oliveira who's been fighting the
OC since I think he was 20 years old
started off eight and eight then win 11
in a row which is [ __ ] insane so yeah
Charles Oliveira you guys got like
Dustin Poore Michael Chandler Justin
gaichi Tony Ferguson you look at the
welterweight division I'm sorry you look
at the lightweight division
you know older cats if you go down gym
for me yeah so you look at Charles
Oliveira he's been doing for a hot
second Dustin Poirier hot second Justin
gaichi hot second uh Chandler hot second
not all new FC but you know Bellator
been fight for a hot second Darius long
on the tooth
um dos anjos the longest tooth
um and then you look at the the other
cats coming up man and there's this
there's just gonna be changing of guard
and you know a lot of their names are
tough to pronounce and it's it's gonna
be
um I just don't see the Belt being
defended a ton of times you're gonna
have the same five characters these
young savages the new age coming up but
I don't see the Belt being you know just
kind of like a Jon Jones style or an
Izzy style or Kamara Usman style where
they're holding it for a long long time
the talent's so good
um but go back to the Cry for Me chin
I'll get to the main because it's tough
because the guy who has the style to
hold for a long time is machev which
we'll get to that uh so you have dariush
gamrat take all my money if just this
fight was on the card I'd pay for a
pay-per-view the hardcore is what the
casuals won't you guys you'll figure it
out camera you're gonna be all over uh
dear skin on the mic you know thank the
Jesus Christ for giving the power to
knock a guy unconscious right and I
enjoy that I don't frown upon that uh so
then you got another fight and Peter
John sugar Shawn O'Malley
and this this is where it gets
interesting because
you know
I'm sure people out there will say does
sugar Shawn deserve this
that's besides it doesn't matter it's
happening so just accept it it's
happening uh deserving is all you know
it's all your perspective you know the
the amount of eyeballs sugar Shawn
brings to the table uh the skill set
that he provides has he walked through
the same fighter as Peter John
absolutely not but
um you know the
the uh damn Marcus smashing those
keyboards but um sugar she just
um but sugar Shawn is a guy that is uh
has the capabilities to be your next
superstar superstar he's already
Superstar and he hasn't fought in the
big big fights he's already
um you know as far as the younger
generation goes he's their guy he's
those young YouTubers and you know the
kids who are vaping getting tattoos and
watching Euphoria Sean O'Malley's their
fighter man they see him not only as a
fighter they see him as a a character
and a talent outside of fighting they'll
see him taking pictures with Takashi 69
and doing his thing and he's dyed hair
and he's on Twitch and he's just got in
this new age where he's making more
money outside of the Octon than he is in
the octagon and people love him he's a
personality
but don't let that rainbow smoke confuse
you the two can fight the dude can fight
not only can the guy fight but the UFC
being smart here because they do need
Stars even though it's not pay-per-view
driven model anymore they still need
Superstars to transcend the sport and
get people to pay attention
O'Malley check out those boxes yeah now
the day and age of um
uh [ __ ] hardwood egg and covered in
Kratom
um the days of like the the massive
stars like Conor McGregor Ronda Rousey a
Brock Lesnar
um I don't know if we can get to that
level anymore with it I don't know
I I just don't know because the
pay-per-view model is not the same so I
I'm not I'm not sure uh but Sean
O'Malley could be the the you know the
testing pool who might be able to get it
done especially here to beat Peter Young
um that would that would get him into
the into this Elite status this elite
club he's been trying to get into
uh I like the idea of him kind of
skipping the line he you know he hasn't
passed a ton of tests to deserve a fight
against Peter John
um you know he he is his last fight
where he uh you know Pedro Munoz in the
eye was an eye poke I I don't know you
know it's it's Up For Debate but it's
not like Sean blew your ears back you're
like that guy's gonna dominate The
bandwid Division you know maybe he just
went on the cards it doesn't matter he
didn't win the fight you know it was no
contest
um and then the one kind of test he had
against Cheeto
listen Pedro and Cheeto could just be
stylistic matchups that don't work for
him so it's tough for him to get into
his Groove but when sugar gets in his
Groove man he's fun to watch
yeah there's not a you know you look at
the strength of schedule
it's tough this is college football you
know he's probably not getting into the
top four BCS bowl games if we if the
season ended right now he's not outside
looking in he's like UCLA they're good
they're good but you ain't run through
that SEC Conference you feel me you're
not you're not playing the Tennessee's
the Alabama's the Ole Miss you're not
doing that buddy but
UFC has hope that he's going to be the
next Guy and um you know
does he deserve it I don't know that's
that's not my that's not my pay grade
that's up to the UFC but um don't get it
twisted they're not doing sugar any
favors Peter Yon
probably the best bantamweight in the
world you know probably is from top to
bottom throughout the schedule uh skill
set as far as footwork boxing striking
wrestling
probably I know I know Al Jermaine beat
him overall though Peter Young you know
you beat Peter John sugar Shawn belongs
in that club he's gonna give that a you
know exclusive Club he's always uh
desired to be in he you gotta walk
through that [ __ ] Russian is Peter
John Russian Chen I think so is he just
straight Russian
I think so right
from Russia but dudinka
yeah we don't need dude that's Russia
baby it says Russia I appreciate the
effort though chair no problem
um
you know
to in order for sugar Shawn in order to
get a title shot and trust me if he wins
this fight guaranteed 100
cash your check now he's fighting for a
title so
um but you're you're walking through the
tough spanway in the world to get that
title shot
this I've been struggling with all day
it's about picks for the UFC 280 really
really struggling with it
um I have some you know close ties with
TJ Joe Shaw is a good buddy of mine uh
Love Shawn O'Malley he's been on the
show multiple times left Sean O'Malley
so it's like man am I just picking these
guys because I want them to win you know
but when I break it down
um there's a few things that favor Shawn
O'Malley in this fight and the UFC knows
what they're doing they're not throwing
Sean O'Malley to the [ __ ] wolves here
he can win this fight he can win this
fight
um it's tough to pick him to win the
fight but I'm gonna do it I I think I'm
gonna go on a limb here and think even
though he's another dog I think Sean
O'Malley the lights can't get bright
enough for him you can't give him enough
attention he's almost like a uh a Conor
McGregor in that aspect or a uh a Paul
brother where you can't get big enough
you're not going to scare them they do
better heard the more lights and cameras
that are on them it's just what he was
born to do so I think we see a version
of sugar Shawn that we've never seen
before I think he's been training harder
than he's ever trained I think he
realizes he knows what's at stake here
because Peter Young loses one he'll go
back you know in the in the into the
queue lose a few spots in the rankings
and he's gonna have to build himself up
and you're gonna build yourself up the
hard way it depends how he you know
Feels by decision that's a different
story but if you were to get like Molly
[ __ ] like ko'd like destroyed then you
you realize he's probably never gonna be
champ right so I don't see that
happening I think Suga knows what's on
the line here and you know for his
career you know he has a kid and a girl
and you know for his brand I just feel
like sugar Shawn we're gonna see a
version and when you fight a guy like
Peter John it brings something out of
you that you weren't even aware was
inside there and I think Suga hasn't
been scared at this point I think Pedro
Munoz scared him I don't think
cheetoscope them these other guys
haven't scared them I think it's the
first time in his life where he has to
check every box he has to get his eight
hours of sleep he has to eat right he
has to you know quit [ __ ] around not
that he is probably not twitch as much I
think he realized what's at stake here
sugar Shawn being younger and so
talented it's you know it's a little bit
of a stretch to pick him but I'm I
there's something I love a guy that does
something special Peter John's already
you know one of the best bandwidths ever
do it uh his legacy cemented I just
there's something about Shawn this fight
being three rounds is an advantage for
sugar Shawn uh perion is a slow starter
by choice when perion comes out you'll
notice in that first in this you know
those first rounds go back you know last
[ __ ] eight fights that first round
he's not very active you know he'll
he'll accept booze I don't give a [ __ ]
so what he does is he downloads the data
he might throw
seven Jabs in the first three minutes
you're like let's get going here Peter
and then he downloads the data and goes
to work and dominates and gets in your
grill
um sugar Sean will have a reach
Advantage here the three rounds
definitely favor sugar Sean
um I'm curious what game plan Peter
John's gonna have
because is he gonna go all right I can't
give away around like I've done before I
can't I don't have three minutes to
download Sugar's movement and all that
stuff I'm just gonna go in there getting
his face close distance he has a reach
not let him get fancy do his footwork do
all this you know chucking and jiving
I'm getting his face and uh just take
that you know kind of and I think he
does incorporate light kicks as as we've
seen Sean struggles with that you know I
know Sean hates when people say I get it
Sean but if you're watching tape you're
probably like well he's not great at it
there's one [ __ ] in the armor there
that we've seen with Cheeto stuff like
that it's just what it is you know I
love you John but if I'm Peter John my
Russian team you know we're like all
right dude
um probably gonna throw some light kicks
so I think you'll see some light kicks
you're gonna see some grappling by yawn
in order to get sugar shine down I think
you guys are gonna be surprised about
sugar Shawn's takedown defense he's
aware that that is a hole that people
want to expose and he's actually pretty
[ __ ] tough to take down he's also
really tall and has leverage
um so this fight is so intriguing to me
besides the main event this most
intriguing fight on the card just
because you have a guy in Sugar who's
young and well there's so much hope and
promise and we've gotten Peter Yan who's
an absolute [ __ ] nightmare and
although sugar does have some advantages
three rounds I think favorite Suga his
reach his movement favors him
um Power definitely goes Peter John
wrestling overall boxing
um and MMA probably Peter yawn but the
outlier of Sean is it's gonna be tough
to emulate him so Peter's probably gonna
lose that first round I think depends on
the game plan I don't know if there's
some rushing in which is you know Shawn
has those knees the jumping knees the
elbows it's a dicey situation but
um this fight is so intriguing to me and
I am a huge Peter John fan but um I'm
gonna take sugar shot O'Malley on this
I know he's the dog I think it would be
so fascinating sugar Shawn one so
fasting
I don't want to talk about what's next
for him let's just see if he gets
through patreon then we can calibrate
how you would do against these other
guys
but for the UFC their worst case
scenario would be if Peter Yan destroyed
sugar shine because you ruined you know
an up-and-coming giant Superstar and
then if Al Jermaine Sterling destroys TJ
Dillashaw
then you're gonna get a what a what are
we in our Trilogy fight of Peter Young
algeman you know
be tough sell be tough sell I'll tell
you what sells sugar shot if here's how
powerful sugar Shawn is
you look at Charles Oliveira first
battle Hall of Famer islamachev trust me
he's giving me a Hall of Famer I'll
Jermaine Sterling Hall of Famer TJ
dilstraw Hall of Famer Peter Young Hall
of Famer Darius gamron they're up there
you know they're up there
if sugar shine pulls off a win against
Peter John he overshadows all of this
that's how big of a name he is he's the
talk of UFC 280. if you were to win
every headline you see because nobody to
be honest and it is what it is this is
my doing nobody attracts more eyeballs
on this entire card than sugar Shawn
O'Malley
if he were to beat the number one
bantamweight in the world every headline
you see I don't care what the [ __ ]
happens in any other finalist card
everything is sugar Shawn O'Malley his
talk goes
his twitch
he's here
through the roof yeah superstar in your
hands you'll see
praying to God that happens because
Peter John said Peter on could lose this
fight and you know he's still gonna be
top three he's a [ __ ] Savage he's so
[ __ ] good at fighting
but he you know he's reached his he's
reached his Peak he has as far as Fame
wise now I don't think he's like out to
pass or anything like that he's
the worst matchup for anybody possible
he can beat anybody on any given night
no matter who the [ __ ] it is he's a
complete Savage but sugar Shawn
has the potential for the UC to put a
[ __ ] rocket on his back and that
rocket is rainbow and it's going high if
he beats Peter John I mean the merge
sails his twitch his podcast his coach
gets more famous you know he's doing
[ __ ] Molly Takashi 69 and Miami these
days you know just getting wild dude and
that's fun
Peter on wins like all right so that's
fun I want fun I like chaos shushon
brings rainbow chaos so I'm picking
sugar shot let's take a little break
from me getting way too crunk for UFC
280 Salt Lake City I will see you this
Thursday Friday Saturday Wise Guys
comedy club that Salt Lake City Saturday
there will be a Salt Lake City fight
campaign with myself and Frank Mayer for
UFC 280 live on thick boy YouTube that
starts at noon Mountain Time come get
you some Salt Lake City I will be in
your city this weekend next weekend well
really next Thursday Friday Thursday
rooftop Calgary Canada the first show on
Thursday is almost sold out so we added
a second show on Friday that's October
27th 28th I'm coming up to Canada
Calgary a November Texas heavy San
Antonio November 3rd to the 5th Houston
November 10th through the 12th and on I
end November in Milwaukee go get your
tickets at thickboy.com
this episode of the shop show is brought
to you by my friends at DraftKings
because UFC 280 is here and DraftKings
is the official sports betting partner
of the UFC and right now customers can
bet just five dollars on UFC 280 and get
200 in free bets if your fighter wins if
you haven't tried draftking Sportsbook
yet right now is the time watch the
fight campaign with myself and Frank
Mayer watch it live with us on thick boy
YouTube at noon Mountain Time 11 A.M
Pacific Time watch it make some Bank
betting with DraftKings all right you
want more action cool can also double
your winnings on a same game parlay
combine multiple bets like which fighter
will win how long will the fight last
and so much more Charles Olivera mock
Jeff if you want to make some Bank bet
on the dog Charles Oliver bet on him and
parlay it him get it done uh and not go
into the scorecards him get it done
under five rounds that's my bet of the
freaking Saturday Fight Card everyone
who wants to boost their winnings place
at UFC 280 same game parlay today
download DraftKings Sportsbook app right
now use promo code shop show that's
schab show throw down five dollars on
UFC 280 and get 200 in free bets if your
fighter wins that's coach shop show this
Saturday at draftking Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner the UFC
minimum age eligibility restriction
Supply see show notes for details
DraftKings
you know me man I like to ride my bike
part of the thick boy bike club I like
to ride my bike and I listen to a lot of
podcasts I listen a little bit of music
and I'll post pictures of me ride my
bike and be like God you listen to you
listen to podcasts or music and you got
wires on your headphones what are you
doing dude was it 2004 yeah because the
earbuds the wireless ones they don't fit
this air my air looks like a tortellini
Myers all jacked up and then I got sent
a pair of raycon wireless earbuds and my
God not only do I hear everything but
they don't fall out because they have
the optimized gel tips it's the perfect
in-ear fit you don't have to worry about
what happened tiny ears big ears
cauliflowers they got you covered man
raycons everyday earbuds look feel and
sound better than ever also raycon gives
you eight hours of Play Time a 32 hour
battery life raycons they're you're one
of what are these three million dollars
now dude you get raycons the Quality
Auto at half the price of other premium
audio Brands is no wonder raycons
everyday earbuds have over 50 thousand
five star reviews I can't get enough of
them they got noise isolation the earbud
tab function awareness mode I'm on my
bike I'm on my own world and they don't
fall on my ears raycon fantastic go to
buy raycon.com Schaub today get 15 off
raycon all right that's by raycon buy
r-a-y-c-o-n.com to score 15 off by
raycon.com
uh this is interesting I would say these
are two of the
these are two I don't want to say this I
would say these are two of the
fighters on the UFC roster who at their
level get the most take
algebra and for whatever reason right
that Peter John fight where you can
continue fighting and just some of the
Antics he's done and then TJ Dillashaw
you know obvious for the EPO and it took
two years off
but my thing is if you're gonna hate on
TJ for that did he not pay the price
in the middle of his prime he was you
know he couldn't work for two years
do we not forgive people is there no
Redemption story
also TJ Joshua he owned it worked his
ass off UFC didn't do many favors two
years off from fighting
and I know a lot of fires that go that
ring Russ isn't real [ __ ] off dude two
years not to be in the UFC and it's not
like a fun two years two years depressed
you got wife you got [ __ ] kids you
know you're still training but you're
not fighting you're not getting paid
there's gonna be some depression there's
some low points two years off
his first fight after two years off
they give him Cody or I'm sorry Corey
sandhagen the Sandman
you guys ranked top three in the world
after two years the fight before that
wasn't even in his goddamn weight class
so really it's three years before he
fought in his [ __ ] weight class dude
it's not insane UFC goes cool dude
here's Corey sandhagen Jesus Christ
now some people go well he didn't beat
him I I disagree with you guys
and also does it matter what you think
the judges in the state of Las Vegas
Athletic commission thought he won and
that's all that matters
so he didn't beat Court cool he did and
now he's playing for the title
think to me you know
at some point you there the thing what
makes America special is redemption
stories we all we're none of us are
flawless everybody [ __ ] up in whatever
capacity some stuff is unforgivable
murder
touch a kid
there's some stuff we there's some stuff
we just can't forgive
PDS other bad mistakes
a lot of us can relate to some of these
bad mistakes Fighters or personalities
or celebrities have done
since when do we just write people off
for mistakes
because if you're that person on the top
of the mountain going oh he should never
be able to fight you hold on you've
never made a mistake and would you want
to be voted off the island forever and
not be able to work that's not how we
work
if he learned from his mistake worked
his ass off came back nice fight for a
title shot you told me the UFC couldn't
use this as a narrative to show a guy
that made an awful mistake
PDS is very prevalent in this business
I know you guys want to make TJ dilshaw
the poster boy of it trust me the guys
that he was fighting were also on some
[ __ ] too
it's just the nature of the business
your favorite fighter has probably
compromised in some way along the lines
I'm not saying they did EPO a lot of
them have a lot of guys that you're
wearing their [ __ ] Reebok fight kit
all that stuff a lot of them have
dabbled in PDS the odds are on my side
on that your favorite NFL quarterback
that you think is God's gift to the
world has probably dabbled in PDS
I hate to ruin your Monday your favorite
basketball player
problem BDS who gives a [ __ ] it's part
of the sport now TJ got caught boy did
he get caught right paid the price for
it no need to get caught but he gets
[ __ ] up by Henry sehudo
paid the price for it took two years off
from working his job couldn't work for
you all you listen this right now it's
not like TJ's
Tom Cruise or Will Smith like Will Smith
[ __ ] up Jesus Christ Will Smith [ __ ]
up Will Smith slapped the guy on live TV
at the Oscars horrible mistake well but
guess what they could vote will off the
island like it's Survivor and he still
has 500 million probably more in the
bank because he did Bad Boys nine or the
[ __ ] he's on it's Will Smith The Fresh
Prince of Bel-Air he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he's fine TJ Dillashaw not fine your
favorite athlete probably not fine if
it's two years from not making any
income it's not cool so not only did TJ
get caught in the embarrassment and the
you know kind of the The Scarlet Letter
on his you know career all good
two years off man he served his time he
served his time he came back yes he
didn't do many favors they threw him
Corey said hey nightmare matchup he
beats him you don't think he beat him
all good don't give a [ __ ] the
commission the judges they beat him it's
very black and white I thought he beat
him so now he's fighting after two years
off after all this ridicule
he's fighting for a [ __ ] bandweight
title of the world how is that not
inspiring to anybody
if you can't take some motivation from
that your glass is half [ __ ] empty
and you're probably leaving YouTube
comments and making a profile on Reddit
right now this is an inspiring story
oh but he
um stop dude everybody makes mistakes
move on he's one of the best
bantamweights to ever do it and he is a
complete [ __ ] Savage nobody wants it
more than TJ Dillashaw here's the other
thing I should root for TJ Dillashaw
serve this time
took the black guy literally
two years off no income wife kids had
another baby
comes back fights Corey sanderhagen
who's ranked number two or whatever in
the world beats him right he's not young
this is it
TJ will never be here again how's
Jermaine still fairly young Al
Jermaine's gonna be fine if he loses
this TJ this is it
this is your closing call my man this is
it he's worked his entire [ __ ] career
for this moment man it's it's inspiring
to me that's why you should root for TJ
America is the land of Second Chances
your favorite movie it's about the guy
falling on Hard Times coming back
getting you know Rocky for God's sakes
[ __ ] Vince Papale heard he was an
[ __ ] but Vince paparly invisible
Philadelphia Eagles they're hot right
now you know everybody likes to come
back story TJ is a comeback story no
matter how you look at it
the caveat with that though him being
his comeback story he's only fought
twice in three years that's a problem
that's a problem that worries me he
didn't look funny
he did enough to beat Corey sanhagen but
it wasn't you know it wasn't like
to argue for the people like he didn't
beat him I'll give you it wasn't easy
and it's Up For Debate sure except for
debate but the point is why I won't even
entertain it because it doesn't matter
the judges the Nevada athletic
commission gave it to TJ dilshaw that's
it move on of course anything is my
[ __ ] guy I love him man it only kids
he was 16. I love him
I thought TJ won that fight I thought
Corey gave him his back too much it's a
horrible look in the judge's eyes
point is though
TJ hasn't been that active and now he's
here it's a comeback story I was remains
gonna be fine it's a very tough matchup
for TJ I do think TJ gets it done I hope
TJ gets it done this is the last
go-around for TJ dilshaw at his age the
way he trains he goes hard man coming
off that injury crazy that's the other
thing coming off the injury great Point
Jim thank you another reason to root for
the guy we've all been injured even if
you're not professional you've been
injured maybe you've had a surgery you
guys know how much that sucks to come
back from the guy coming off an injury
dude
remember he beat Corey sagging on one
leg
One lag dude
you know I talk about uh
all the time like a mama mentality stuff
like that dude TJ has that
TJ dude is he's it's rare I say it's
about Fighters but so I'm Peter John
being Russian I'm sure he's down there's
a few fighter swords straight up willing
to die in there Josh Barnett famous for
saying that
I was more well known by throwing that
as soon as you see me and throw you
throw that [ __ ] towel I got [ __ ] to
do I'm not Russian I'm not TJ dylashall
I'm trying to do stamp coming I don't
want to die in here I would be tragic
this is not my calling card
it's TJ's calling card it's Peter John's
calling card this Islamic Chef telling
card Charles Oliver's calling card this
is what they do those guys are willing
to die in there TJ takes it to another
level he's obsessed with it
TJ's a guy a little story about TJ we
have the same uh coach and TJ still uses
his name's Lester Bowen I've talked
about Eastern if you listen to the show
since it was Big Brown breakdown you've
heard at least her bowling's name
mentioned a few times at least sure
bowling was
he was a he's a Colorado High School
wrestling Legend
undefeated uh then he went to I forget
the name of the school but he was uh on
the same wrestling team with Ben
Henderson Ben was younger than him
in high school 300 now whatever the [ __ ]
his son's a beast right and uh he comes
from a family of wrestlers his dad was
wrestlers kids are wrestlers uncles are
wrestlers all they [ __ ] was wrestling
he looks like a [ __ ] a spark plug
with two eyes he looks like a [ __ ]
fire hydrant that somebody put white
face on and a few warts and he is filled
with piss and vinegar there we are he's
filled with piss and vinegar and he's
the toughest son of a [ __ ] you know if
you if you're in trouble you want least
you're bowling your [ __ ] Foxhole I
hate him wearing that hat and I also
just look at it that was the night that
I knocked out Christopher and Shang
fought Brock Lesnar Shane lost that's
why he's so depressed there I'm pretty
crunk cause I won 58 sorry I'm sorry I
won a minute six and on the elevator
going up after The Knockout I'm on the
elevator with uh Dwayne Johnson The Rock
wow yeah he's told me he's a fan and all
this [ __ ] nice that was pretty cool I
looked down he had uh platform he was on
whatever
um so uh back to Easter bowling
so he was a coach at uh he'd helped the
University of Northern Colorado team out
Shane had a relationship with him
because Shane lived in Greeley so I was
allowed to go to the University of
Northern Colorado and do the wrestling
program so I was wrestling with like the
heavyweights and the light in the middle
way so that was my introduction to
wrestling so I'm there that's right
before yep there's Shino
um
so once me and Shane started doing that
then we uh you know we started how to
start a grudge then all the grudge guys
start coming up and how to guys so you
got Rashad Evans in there and there's a
great picture of Rashad Evan's son and
Lisa Bowen's son who both wrestle and
they're like four and they're just like
dead serious getting after in front of
each other that's one of my favorite
pictures but
um once people realize who Lisa bowling
was and the his knowledge on wrestling
then GSP started to use at least or
bowling and then you got [ __ ] The
Who's Who using Lisa ball and they're
flying them out to Greg Jackson's and
you know he's this guy and he he's a guy
who I always appreciate he didn't want
fame he didn't want to be the pictures
he just wanted to do the work he helps
Neil magni out he's the one that got
Justin Gates into MMA Justin gaichu was
a All-American wrestler at University of
Northern Colorado and he wanted to get
into MMA at least to induce him to
Trevor the rest is history just in case
she's a multi-time world champion one of
the biggest names in the UFC so yeah
Neymar carts using them he's working
with [ __ ] everybody's the point
um
so
least or bowling takes on TJ dillashall
they they click because they're both
insane they're both out of their minds
all they give a [ __ ] is about like
breaking people it's literally that all
they want to do is break people it's
insane insane
um so TJ and uh Lisa bowling have the
same mindset that Kobe break you at all
costs when it all class mentality they
become like peanut butter and jelly
TJ's so drawn to at least they're
bowling in the way he works and uh
leaster bowling opens up his own
college-like wrestling camp for his kids
and has the whole kids massive Kids Camp
Builds on his like [ __ ] Ranch
TJ dillashall getting ready for the
croissanting if I end this fight
TJ has money right TJ won the fight he
has some sponsors he's a smart
businessman now he has he has like a
juice truck that we've used on the show
we got T John he can come back after
this fight and probably do the juice
truck which I'm starving all day by
pretended school but um TJ's such a
[ __ ] sociopath when it comes to
fighting
he leaves his wife and kids and he
sleeps in the wrestling room it's not a
nice restroom it's okay it's still
wrestling where we've all been there
there's staff everywhere he sleeps on a
sleeping bag in the bunk beds during
Camp to get him to get his mindset
uncomfortable to get ready for these
fights
that's what you're dealing with
that's a comeback story that guy is
willing to do whatever it takes to win
this fight I don't know if Al Jermaine
Sterling is willing to do that
now you can turn TJ's lights off a knee
you get his back algebra is fantastic on
the back he's explosive
if you don't land something like that
I'm telling you TJ is willing to go
places you're not willing to go
the the amount of
the amount of I don't say hate or
animosity I don't know what you would
call it the amount of drive that TJ
dilshaw has very few athletes have in
all sports
Kobe had it Jordan had it they're all
[ __ ]
DJ's not gonna win any nice guy Awards
with his friends he is with his family
he's the [ __ ] best
trading partner stuff like he's gonna be
tough man because he has one goal only
and that's to be the very very [ __ ]
best and he'll do whatever it takes to
be the best literally whatever he's
willing to go places I'd be willing to
bat two other guys on the card are
willing to go and their names Islam and
Peter Young and they're not American
TJ has their mindset plus 10. he's a
Savage this is his time and his thing
that's why I feel so much pressure about
this it's this last time
he's a comeback story if you don't view
TJ dilstraw's a comeback story you're a
hater you ain't [ __ ]
TJ's earned this
DJ's walk through the fire TJ's taking
all the criticism he owns all that he
paid his dues move on even algermanos
he's still using stuff come on dude you
gotta do better than that
now now Al Jermaine gonna talk that [ __ ]
now you gotta fight the guy and good
luck and I like Al join as a person
Dallas train is fantastic he's been on
food truck he's fantastic algeman is a
good human a fantastic [ __ ] fighter
he's your [ __ ] world champion
taking TJ Dillashaw
taking DJ via decision
now we're just getting to the main event
that's how good this [ __ ] fight is
that's a long round of TJ hopefully I
sold some of you on rooting for TJ I
know people won't hate on teachers now
Jermaine you're looking at your
perspectives completely off you're just
off man TJ paid his Deuce move the [ __ ]
on the main event Charles Oliveira
islamak Jeff I've struggled with this
for about four weeks on today's show
picking a fight for this part of me went
maybe I'm not gonna pick this time you
can't do that dude you're like what are
you [ __ ] oh now you're a real
journalist nope so I gotta pick
but I also don't piss anybody off but I
also have no ties to Charles or Islam at
all so I can pick this one but I go back
and forth part of the problem is
the person I know that knows Islam
muchev the most is Josh Thompson I was
just in San Jose Josh comes to the show
he's waiting in line to meet and greet
I'm like you don't have to get up here
dude I got he goes oh what are you hold
on like we gotta give this because
there's a line real quick how does Islam
beat Charles
and Josh to be fair had a few drinks but
still knows his [ __ ] remember he's the
captain of AK he's been without Islam
since he first came in and he goes how
how's Charles beat him I go where do I
start Josh he's more dangerous in every
capacity of mixed martial arts you tell
me where Islam's better wrestling I'll
give you that outside wrestling
submissions off the back submissions on
the top and uh transitions Charles the
and it's noted the best ever do it most
submission bonuses of all time Savage
these great office back great on top
transitions even when the guys take him
down he can get your neck you have a
[ __ ] million reasons to worry about
that guy if you're trying to take him
down check Charles Oliveira on the feet
Charles Oliveira more dangerous better
striking
strength of schedule
look what Charles Oliver has done in the
last 18 [ __ ] months dude look at the
people he's what
excuse me
this dude
look at this this dude
in his last
let's just do last one two three four
five let's go over his last six this is
where it gets fun for us
this is Charles Olivera's last six
fights you tell me if any of these names
ring a bell
Kevin Lee
and this is 2020 Kevin Lee Savage he
beat him Guillotine choke submission
performance of the night you must wait
I'll get performance of the night
next fight was against Tony Ferguson
December 2020.
then he fought Michael Chandler ever
heard of him Michael Chandler he tkos
him in the second round
survived an onslaught first round could
have been 10-8 that was a prime Michael
Chandler Chandler made some mistakes
that but still
Charles love Road [ __ ] TKO knocks out
Michael Chandler
then he fights Dustin Poirier
fat dust and Poirier beat him rear naked
choke
I don't say it was easy fight but he
beat him
then he give him Justin gate you which I
thought was a bad matchup for him
he starts just uh Justin Kechi gets his
back chokes him out
so he's choked out
Kevin Lee
doesn't pour a black belt and Justin
gaichi
out of those last uh one two three four
five fights one two three four five
those five
uh three out of those five are ranked on
top three at the time
he didn't beat him by decision
he's finishing them
that's Charles Oliveira the ultimate
finisher
so when you look at strength to schedule
and so I go back and forth on it it's
like all right Charles Oliver is more
dangerous than every [ __ ] capacity of
mixed martial arts
but to argue for islamakita
Islam is a guy who we've been told how
good he is
Javier Mendez who nothing but the utmost
respect for in the world is a you know
world-class coach he says he's the best
lightweight ever okay there's some hype
there khabib tells us he's the next
champ kabib knows a thing or two about
fighting khabib's you know arguably the
greatest lightweight to ever do it
that's his guy they came up together
they trained together okay but that's
also hyped there right Josh Thompson
dude never seen this guy lose around in
training you see what he does to this
guy tells me all the war strikes which I
love he gets me rock hard tells me all
this crazy [ __ ] about Islamic how much
of a badass he is cool got it
I've seen any of this you guys tell me
I've seen any of it
none of it
none of it
I haven't seen any of it his best win
drew dober's a good win Drew dober's
dangerous but good matchup for him there
you go Thiago Moses Diego Moses okay
Dan hooker tough character tough guy bad
match for Dan hooker Bob green short
notice
all right
so his best win is probably over
[ __ ]
Dan hooker
this Goodwin
you know so start the schedule so
if you believe the hype you think Mike
just gonna win this fight Vegas believes
the hype
I will argue for mock Jeff here for you
guys if you think about putting money on
this fight
the one knock on Charles Olivera even
though he
is you know he's the champion he's the
best way but we all know he's the
champion even though he's a champion the
knock on Charles Olivera as he does get
hit he does take punishment you look at
all those fights that I mentioned the
gaichi the Dustin Poirier the Chandler
fight uh besides 21st he was in a ton of
trouble but you look at his career
especially early on if the Paul Felder
was vicious
um you know he takes some some hits man
he's a guy who takes chances and and mo
get hit
um so that's worrisome because remember
he's been fighting since he's 20 years
old
you know it's back hallway fight you
know you know kept Swanson fight he got
knocked out in uh donceroni tko'd him
earliest career I don't care too much
about that but my point is is he's not
young father time is going to come
fairly soon he's on the last leg of his
career it's been a [ __ ] phenomenal
Creator win 11's insane especially at
this level
it's gonna come I don't know if it comes
this Saturday afternoon
Morgan of uh Salt Lake fight campaign 11
A.M uh mountain time I don't know if you
can come then
It's Gonna Come
but the point is is Charles Oliveira and
one of the reasons we love him and the
one of the reasons he gets so many
finishes is because he takes chances
after getting ko'd in the UFC a hot
second ago takes no chances he got
knocked out seven years ago Islam takes
zero chances zero risk he does whatever
it takes to win the fight even if it's
boring he's gonna win that fight now if
you give up some sort of thing if you're
not that versed on the ground he's going
to submit you but he's not a khabib stop
where he's going to break the [ __ ] out
of here make it miserable where you want
out and you're gonna quit he's not there
yet
the issue with that is if you're Charles
Olivera fan and that's why I struggle
with picking who's going this fight is
because makachev doesn't really give
anybody openings to take advantage and
finish the fight anymore
he's going to go in and do exactly what
he needs to do to win the fight all he
cares about is being champ well that's
laying on Charles Oliver for five rounds
and for 25 minutes he does not care just
wants to be champ
that's tough man when a guy has that
skill set and he knows he's dealing with
a guy who's a complete Savage and can
put you out in any point of the fight
you're not going to see a lot of risk
taken by Maka chef
he's a safe route
he's a safe route he's the safe bet
but there's something about Charles O
levera that throws those Hail Marys at
any given time
and I do think
Jeff's gonna get him down guaranteed get
them down would bet my last [ __ ]
dollar gets them down
but when you take Charles Oliver down
you gotta worry about a significant
amount of other things that you don't
with other guys your neck even if you
think it's the right place it's not in
the right place in the transition if you
don't get them control them those
transitions he's getting the [ __ ] that
you're not preparing for he's getting to
that neck he's getting the darches and
the arm triangles and [ __ ] you you
haven't seen yet he's the best in the
world at it
Islam knows this you know so it's just
how much
is is I'm willing to go through to to
you know
to make it entertaining I don't think he
gives a [ __ ] about entertaining you guys
which is why he's not we all want since
he could be retire all this is his best
friend though khabib says he's the next
big thing I get that he's not khabib
khabib's a special dude khabib also is a
beast on the mic Islam hates interviews
Islam hates the bright lights the lights
will never be brighter ever in his
career than come Saturday night in Abu
Dhabi those lights are bright as [ __ ]
when you're fighting for the light
lightweight title of the world and
you're facing Charles Oliveira who's won
the best ever do it
so for Islam there's some pressure
because your coach said you're the best
of all time and you sure as [ __ ] don't
have the resume to prove it khabib says
you're the best of all time Josh
Thompson says your best of all time this
is MMA royalty at its highest crowning
you champ before you even champ ton of
pressure on him the guy hasn't had this
type of pressure
I know I won't say who it is told me the
only thing Islam needs to work on is
showing up when the lights are brightest
he's not used to that yet we haven't
seen his full potential because he
hasn't fought in those big moment fights
so how's he going to fight against a guy
in Charles Oliveira because if you if
you're even take one one second You Take
Your Eye Off the price for one second
Charles Oliver's gonna get your neck or
you can throw an elbow and that fight's
over
can Islam do that for 25 minutes Vegas
thinks he can
khabib thinks he can
his coach thinks he can
most the media thinks he can
I don't think so
I don't think so 25 minutes in there
with Charles Oliveira
I feel pretty confident he's the most
dangerous guy inside the rock gun of all
time
the bonuses will prove that as well
we'll back that up I think for 25
minutes you're gonna fight safe it's
gonna be a tough night in the office for
you I think even if you get Charles
Oliver down he's gonna be so dangerous
off his back Islam's not going to want
to be down there and then they're gonna
be forced to be on their feet and that's
where Charles Oliver excels and has more
Tools in his chamber to get this fight
out of there now if this fight is a
decision hands down just walk away from
the TV Islam one this goes the judges
Charles ain't beating him via decision
Charles again taking down multiple
multiple [ __ ] times I guaran [ __ ]
to you unless he starts in the first few
minutes I don't see that happening but
I just I've I've second guessed Charles
Oliver for too long even though he's my
Dark Horse you remember this gin for
years I said Charles Oliver is the Dark
Horse he's gonna be a champion like he
can do it all if he has the right
mindset my only caveat with Charles
Oliveira for the longest time and boy
was I wrong he proved me wrong I said he
has quit in him whenever I see a guy
quit there's no way to come back from
that he proved me wrong I know what if
you saw a mental coach one of the just
or just confidence from knocking these
great Fighters out the the quit is not
in there in him anymore he would have
quit against Michael Chandler he would
have quit against some of these other
guys that's gone now you just have this
Savage who has all the confidence in the
world and he's the most dangerous guy
from the floor to the feet to ever
compete in the Afghan the bonuses back
that statement up and you're locked in
there for 25 minutes
it's tough for me to pick against
Charles Oliveira it's tough
I don't know how long he's me champ
here's the thing
with Charles style and with Father Time
Coming
you know maybe another year it's gonna
be tough
Islam does have the style even though
this younger in the in the tides turn
like he started this whole Riot before I
started the Pod I'm sorry in the
beginning pod of how the Tide's turning
the these Legends the in the lightweight
division across the board in the UFC
these Legends are slowly going out to
pasture and this new wave of [ __ ]
monsters is coming and at lightweight it
is heavy it is packed with names that
are hard to pronounce
gamrod is a [ __ ] Savage dude yeah I'm
like on any given day could be Charles
all over Islam he's a Savage
Islam does have the style where he could
hold on to the belt for quite some time
if he plays it safe you're not gonna win
any fans over but he does have that
style and the ability to hold onto the
belt for two or three fights but I don't
I sure as [ __ ] don't see it with these
younger guys coming up and the skill set
they have him holding it for like a
Kamar Usman style Reign or a Izzy style
Reign or Jon Jones Reign that's not
having that light at lightweight I
guarantee it's not happening this
younger generation are [ __ ] Savages
here's the style to do that but there's
no way it's going to happen
so overall my picks
um for
UFC 280
will be Sean Brady Muhammad you know I
[ __ ] love you uh Sean Brady Philly's
Finest it's tough to pick against him
the Eagles right now so I'm just going
based off the Eagles doing their damn
thing and chambray's such a Savage he's
been my Underdog Dark Horse in the
welterweight division he's gonna fight
for a title next year I guarantee you I
take Sean Brady via submission I will
take uh I hate this Darius I'll take
gamrod
I'll take game right for your decision
I'll take sugar Shawn O'Malley
I'll take TJ dillashall and Charles
Oliveira Charles levere by Finnish I
don't know what round
I have no idea when he pulls it off I
think he's gonna be down on the
scorecards and pull it off he's gonna
have to walk through some [ __ ] tough
tough fire to pull this off but 25
minutes most dangerous guy to ever do it
knees elbows submissions punches kicks
I'll take my chance of Charles de Lavera
I think Charles Glover gets it done via
decision that'd be my bad [ __ ] parlay
Charles wins via you know finish
um if he goes to judges it's Islam by
landslide
uh like I said Charles decision I'm
sorry Charles finish uh under five
rounds TJ Dillashaw I'll probably say
via finish five rounds I think DJ
finished Al Jermaine
um sugar Shawn
best bet would be decision I could see
him get a finish with a knee or
something because he does have the reach
and perion I think is going to
incorporate wrestling wrestling and then
game rap view decision Sean Brady via
submission those are my pictures 280
that was [ __ ] tough to pick tough
card great card such good card like I
told you guys earlier we're doing uh I
want to call it calabas fight command
but it's nowhere near Calabasas we
should call it the Mormon companion it's
uh the Salt Lake City fight companion
and that will be with me and Frank mayor
plus some other gas that is live 11 A.M
mountain time that will be 12 uh Pacific
Time live on thick boy YouTube come
watch this amazing card with me
see my grand old time me and Frank are
some chatty Kathy's 11 Pacific right 11
yeah my bad 11 A.M Pacific time that
would be 12 mountain time okay
which is Mormon time
enjoy the fights man I'm in this guide
for a fight top to bottom in a hot
[ __ ] second stacked I could have done
a four-hour podcast breaking down the
prelims
I'm told not to do that anymore
there's some phenomenal fights and so
many names we can't pronounce on here
and boy does uh Bruce Buffer have his
work got out for them you read some of
those names like Jesus Christ Bruce good
luck buddy
enjoy that magamed mustard mustafive
verse Yamato nishikawa not bad not bad
not bad at all that cry live ozed mayor
take my [ __ ] money
fantastic fight
it's just there's so many good fights on
here so many good fights let's do some
current events too we also have that one
on Amazon Prime video three fight world
is popping bad astronomical knockout
artist yes you got a great uh fight and
that's on Friday I believe a Saturday is
it Saturday uh Friday in Singapore it
says or it's actually in two different
ones
so you have fried well uh yeah it's
Friday I think well 8 P.M on 20th on the
21st is Friday 8 PM EDT and October
October 22nd which Saturday 8 A.M Sgt so
so that may if it's 8 AM Sgt that means
it's prime time for us if it's on uh
Amazon Prime Prime Primetime first
meeting in in North America right gotcha
uh it's a great card though you got John
lineker who's just doing work defending
his belt against Fabricio andrage andras
is a uh he's also a knockout artist so
we'll see
we'll see we can deliver man but his
star is a Boomin I'm most excited for
the guy who just won 80cc he just won
the submission grappling World title and
uh it's again one championship
setting the standard man you have a
straight up submission grappling World
title on a big ass event on Amazon Prime
you got your boy Cade and he's competing
for the second time ever on one
championship for the world title and you
would know him because he just destroyed
the Abu Dhabi combat championships ADCC
so go get you some and they also got the
20 year old uh this this she's such a
badass uh California you guys would know
her uh uh Leah Bivens she won the she's
been in the headlines here because she
won the Colorado State uh wrestling
California state yeah California State
wrestling championship
um one Championship spanked on this
youngster at 20 to be the next American
Star so there's a lot of fun storylines
there you got that Jiu Jitsu Phenom and
Cade coming off his championship on ADCC
you also got John lineker who went over
to one Championship left the UFC is just
on fire got a title damage and that's uh
one championship's third card on Amazon
Prime and uh go get you some man it's
gonna be a fun one
stacked this week man oh yeah you got
that and you see 280 take all my money
thanks Amazon thanks one championship
so over the weekend Deontay Wilder ko'd
his opponent
um his name is helenius and I guess they
were sparring partners before
I don't know if you saw his post like
press conference but yeah so I saw uh
just a picture of him like crying but
what's weird is uh it was like a it
wasn't like a huge shot I thought it was
a left but then if when I saw around
like yeah almost like this then it's
just like uh yep but it the a certain
angle looks pretty flushed yeah but this
one's it was kind of hard to tell
yes
[Music]
this is the first round too right
boom
[Applause]
I mean out cold
yeah out cold and then Deontay during
the press conference um
he was well let me just play this clip
for you because I think it's pretty
powerful
um but you know my heart goes out to him
and I hope he's doing okay he can be
able to go back to his family because
this is a tough business that we're in
the toughest that's why I tell people
you got to respect all fighters
you know people always go about worrying
about Wreckers and and all this he lost
all he's a bum and all that when you get
your bomb ass in there then and let's
see who's the bomb really because you
don't play this you can't play this
so we we demand respect at all times
everybody that step in the ring I don't
care what the record is I don't care who
they are or where they come from it
demands respect because if not
then you see things like that happen
and then all we were oh that's a good
night yeah that's a great knockout it's
devastating making history and stuff
like that but
how much that man gonna suffer
he may be all right right now a little
bit but what about the next day
what about around five years two weeks
from now what about a month from now
maybe years from now
and we seeing what happened look at look
at look at cologne
correct
this man ain't have no kids
[Music]
I mean y'all don't [ __ ] understand
what we go through man
and I don't even know him like that
but I always be an advocate for us
because ah
this man would never know what it feel
like to be somebody's father
and that's something the precious thing
in the world to be somebody father
yeah
but he'll never be nobody father man
this man I never have a natural
childhood ability of of a living again
because of he got in the ring to support
his family
but now
his family got to take care of him for
the rest of his life he might he
probably would have been he probably
would have bread wouldn't help his
family
and now they looking seeking for help
and [ __ ] like that
I could say so much about it
so I looked into that Pritchard uh
Cologne guy he's like he was undefeated
killer and then his last fight
he got brain damage and he's in a
vegetative state right now the most
exciting prospects in boxing the Puerto
Rican uh Pritchard cologne last for the
first time in his professional career
however the blows he received in the
fight because damn brain damage left him
in a vegetative state Jesus Christ like
this was his record
just that one fight
yeah so that's what yeah Deontay was
referencing no I mean deante is 100
right Deontay is such a good person
yeah such a good guy such a sweet guy
now for him to kind of bring this back
full circle and not make you so sad uh
for Deontay Wilder he needed this win so
now you're talking about like a Ruiz
fight which would be fun
um I know he's calling for Anthony
Joshua which obviously Joshua Fury is
not fighting which is beyond me why
that's not [ __ ] happening so Wilder
Josh would be a great [ __ ] fight and
then also there's talk to Wilder Francis
and Gano and I think for France I was
talking with his agent yesterday Martel
who had absolutely adore Martel I was
like man Francis Deonte now he's gonna
be an underdog whether it's Fury or
Deontay Wilder but he'd be less of an
underdog against Wilder
Fury has too much skill to just get
clipped by the right hand early on it'd
be a very tough fight for Francis now
Francis lands you know who knows what
would happen but with wilder Wilder you
know we'll play that game a little bit
well it has a big right hand for
instance big right hand sign me up yeah
it's a much better still probably uh
plus 500 Underdog at least Fury is
probably a plus two thousand you know
I like the Deontay Wilder fight for him
deonto is like if the money makes sense
the fight makes sense I was like all
right let's do it my man that'd be fun
it's the only predicated on the UFC
coming agreements with Francis
because France I think wants to box like
do a water fight and then fight John and
you'll see saying no no we're going to
resign you fight John and then maybe
we'll be open to boxing Francisco no no
I want to box and then fight so that's
the hold up we'll see what happens here
and that's by the way um it's official
well not official official but I think
Ariel helwani posted after you mentioned
it that the whole Jon Jones thing with
denganu potentially December 10th or
steepe Ariel posted it like four days
after yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm sure I said the news and then
yep you both guys do what journalists do
and call and cover their bases I don't I
get from the horse's mouth and then I
don't double check with anybody and
sometimes it hits yep all right so UFC
obviously Mark Zuckerberg's been around
USA for a little while now but they have
officially partnered up with them for
something called meta live and on-demand
events where they're doing virtual
reality
things for Fight Pass and they did it
for the first time at LFA that just
happened and this is what it looks like
this is basically you walking through
the arena
the way metaverse works that's a real
fight but they'll take you there yeah
interesting there's a bunch of cameras
and he's pretty badass but she was like
this big big fights pretty cool
we knew someone's gonna come between
those two of course yeah
and some quick fight uh quick bout
announcements Alexander Gustin and oven
Saint Peru they'll be fighting UFC 282
that's that light heavyweight uh yeah it
has to be let me double check I think
it's like though because they're both
dabbled in heavyweight yeah cool that's
a good fight
um and also
Jan blockowitz versus magamed unclelay
damn December 10th yeah tasty
oh man that's a tough fight for y'all
yep yeah that's a great fight dude
your boy tattoo versus Sergey pavlovich
that's a fight night in Orlando December
3rd
and this is
pavlovich's record right now he's coming
off that one over uh the Blackberry
Blues yeah and then Ty just lost his
Earl yeah uh let's see Yuri pohaska and
Global Tech Sierra too that's official
now for 282 as well what's interesting
about that is I know they're waiting to
see if yours can be the main event if
John said no they're gonna make your
internet Event John was gonna push it
towards you know January February and
wait for Francis
um then year would be the main event but
it still sounds like John's on December
10th against cepe damn that's gonna be
six yeah Main Event co-main Event
uh this is another uh it's not official
but Ron Garcia and Javonte Davis has
been going going back and forth on
social media and it looks like they
might have a fight in December and this
is the the last thing that I think this
last thing they posted they both said it
was done deal man it's a tough fight for
Ryan Grace I know
and Ryan's calling for it though I know
yeah maybe they see something Ryan's a
little beast dude
yeah I love that fight though
I was gonna be so excited yeah great
fight
and just quick one on Aspen live she's
gonna be fighting um Julia bud
get yep
I'd prefer to get a straight title shot
but whatever
uh this was we already talked about this
a little bit but the whole slot fighting
thing apparently Dana White and Lorenzo
Fertitta are teaming up again to have
that slight slot fighting thing happen
in Nevada and it's like in real talks
now with the commission and everything
and it uh slapping that's just when they
just stand there and slap you yeah and
then they're you're I'm sure you met
Craig polygian he's the guy that created
tough with them oh yeah producer guy
yeah he's the only gave him my shot yeah
yeah so they're teaming up by him again
too so they might be doing like a
reality show who knows
slapping that's weird
um this is weird how's Bula you guys all
know hezboola yeah he posted he posted
that he was officially signed to the UFC
to fight
right which obviously No One's Gonna
really believe but they're see this
right here
and then he also is going to have his
fight kit out for people to purchase
I think the fight kit might actually do
well I was gonna say I would never buy a
fight get but I'd buy that one yeah yeah
he's not gonna fight um
yeah I you know the UFC marketing team
you know with hezboola you know
obviously with his massive following his
connection khabib and then you know the
the milk boys stuff like that they're
just doing the anything to get this
younger generation yeah I mean if it
works yeah I get it I get it no hate
there
Oscar De La Hoya is picking Jake Paul
to KO Anderson Silva interesting you say
why that's a good fight Oscar says I'm
gonna go with Jake Paul yeah I'm gonna
go with Jake Paul just because he seems
like he's getting to the rhythm of
things he doesn't have too many fights
less boxing hard worker
a lot of power if he connects with
Sylvie's gonna knock him out if he
touches civil he's gonna he's going down
everybody's going baseball did the Julio
Cesar Chavez Jr and tit Ortiz come on I
mean Shabbos June wasn't even 20 himself
okay condition wise physically just
wasn't him
all right yeah so he believes Jake Paul
will likely get the KO and so the
pay-per-view passes for that fight came
in can you guess how much it is
Jake doesn't want to ostrich his fan
base I'll say 49.99 close enough 59.99
yeah yeah smart with that
and okay this is just
I'll just play it for you this is Bryce
Mitchell talking about jiu jitsu's or
Jiu Jitsu practitioners in MMA so
usually I get on here and I complain
about the government but today I'm gonna
complain about something even better
something that I know that I know what
I'm talking about I'm gonna complain
about jiu jitsu
and yeah I love Jujitsu I use it every
time I'm in a fight okay but the problem
with the sport of Jiu Jitsu today
is all y'all fight like a bunch of
sissies
all y'all want to do is pull guard and
go for leg locks and and I get it that's
great you get your little gold medal you
get that's cool you get your gold medal
you get to stand on the podium woo
yeah but when you get in a fight at
Walmart and you go for a leg lock you
get stomped in the face and you get your
teeth knocked out okay
you get kicked right into nuts your nuts
are wide open okay you or the bad dude
gets away runs away
okay so get up off your ass and fight
and I think the best jujitsu guy I've
ever seen
well Andrew Wilt sees a good one because
he he knows how to take people down
Andrew Wilson
um Nikki rod these are guys that fight
like men okay they get up they get a
hold of you they throw you to the ground
and then proceed to do their Jujitsu all
you other punks out there that that are
fought starting to match on your butt
and scooting at the guy y'all are
sissies and and every one of y'all
you need to stop fighting like chickens
okay
a bunch of chickens out there
a bunch of chicken [ __ ]
get up off your ass like nasty
yeah I mean yeah I don't like to start
anybody either what's that I don't like
starring the how do you let him star in
their butt the problem is too you know I
don't know how many people are gonna get
in fights at Walmart anyone can be like
an actual Street Walmart can be a little
dicey but also I'll tell you right now
if it's the average Joe Versus those
guys that do those like lots trust me
that guy's not stopping anybody in the
head they're gonna rip his [ __ ]
Achilles heel off yeah it's gonna be a
nightmare
um you I think he talked about this
outside but so Tito Ortiz is saying that
him and chill son have a fight yep 2023
yep February 23. I have more news for
that uh for you guys I'm sure Frank
allude to it when we do the fight
campaign sweet break some news for you
guys
I know the rest of the lineup as well
and let's just end on this then just a
Mackenzie during appreciation thing
that's her do you see what I see good
things coming soon that's after her
fight yeah and she also looks very
pretty you're so pretty yeah
yep that's a good way to end it Jen cool
and it was on a positive note a dime
piece
well kids a lot going on this weekend I
will be in Salt Lake City Utah this
Thursday Friday Saturday Salt Lake City
then Saturday live on thick boy at 12 uh
uh Mountain Time that'd be 11 A.M
Pacific Time live on thick boy YouTube
we have a Salt Lake City fight companion
for you guys with myself and Frank mayor
some special guests
um as far as tour dates uh Salt Lake
City this Thursday through Saturday Wise
Guys my favorite clubs next week
Thursday Calgary almost sold out Calgary
rooftop we added a second show on Friday
at the rooftop That's Thursday Friday
next week in Calgary Canada the thick
boys will be up in Canada doing the damn
thing and then that Saturday we have
another Calabasas an actual calabas
fight campaign from my home turf home
studio for the uh Jake Paul
um Anderson Silva fight
um so make sure you tune into that and
then November gets pretty Texas heavy
you got San Antonio at the LOL with my
favorite clubs in San Antonio November
3rd through the 5th you Houston Texas
Houston props November 10th to 10th
through the 12th Houston Improv
Milwaukee November 18th through the 19th
that's just Friday Saturday Milwaukee
because I can't leave Thursday so I'm
walking November 18th 19th Houston San
Antonio November Salt Lake City this
week Calgary Canada next week Thursday
Friday get your tickets at thickboy.com
that's it kids I will see you guys
Saturday uh live on the thick boy
YouTube for the Salt Lake City fight
companion with Frank Mayer for UFC 280.
enjoy the fights this weekend I will see
you Monday be nice to each other stay
safe love you guys see ya
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
John lineker touches you he hurts you
foreign
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding